[Music]
oh
something new is on the horizon
[Music]
our destination is this archipelago made
up of several islands
known as a resort this locale is popular
among characters searching for their
ideal vacation homes
[Music]
this is animal crossing new horizons
happy home paradise
[Music]
after a reference from tom nook you'll
assist paradise planning a resort
developer in designing vacation homes
[Music]
through your work you'll be in charge of
coordinating dream lifestyles for
characters
the goal of paradise planning is to help
characters acquire their dream vacation
homes
characters with various dreams come to
visit the office on this island
[Music]
for example meet maple
her dream vacation home is filled with
lots and lots of bears
let's make her dream a reality
first select the island on which the
vacation home will be built
each island has distinctive features
yards for instance may differ from
island to island
[Music]
pick the island that best matches the
request then head on over to the site
once you arrive on the island take a
tour of the home
place the designated furniture requested
by the client
[Music]
after that everything else is up to you
[Music]
recommended furniture from paradise
planning will already be available
pick which ones you'd like to use to
start designing
create depth by adding lighting to the
ceiling
[Music]
spice up a wall with some wallpaper as
well
[Music]
it looks fantastic
while you're at it why not suggest ideas
for the yard
[Music]
not only can you place furniture
you can also build fences
plant trees
[Music]
and create paths
[Music]
the home's location and exterior can be
modified too
and with the ability to modify the
season time of day and weather you can
bring a design to life that's in perfect
harmony with nature
seems like the client is pretty happy
[Music]
as you continue designing vacation homes
you'll acquire various design techniques
[Music]
for example adjusting the size of the
interior by modifying its width or
length more creative design options will
become available
[Music]
in addition you can use partition walls
to divide the space
counters with two different heights
[Music]
and pillars that support the ceiling
each can help change how the home is
structured
lighting can be adjusted as well to
enhance the overall mood
[Music]
[Applause]
and you can incorporate soundscapes to
add depth to the home's atmosphere
finally polishing can give a finishing
touch to the interior design
polish your furniture with care and some
effects may be added
[Music]
why not give your furniture a new
flourish
after a hard day's work head back to the
office to get compensated for your
efforts
a shop space within the office sells
rare furniture that may be hard to find
on your island
once purchased you can take it home with
you
[Music]
as you receive more requests more
furniture will become available
why not visit clients you've helped out
before
it might be good to suggest remodeling
their vacation home with different
furniture
[Music]
with your recommendation two clients can
share a vacation home
we hope they love sharing their new
piece of paradise
[Music]
say
the island on which lottie's paradise
planning office is located has a lot of
vacant buildings
you can help lottie design these as well
to make the island even more robust
take schools for example design one by
drawing inspiration from your own
memories or craft the school of your
dreams instead
other facilities such as a restaurant
can also be developed
you may be delighted seeing others using
the facilities you've designed
[Music]
the vacation homes you design are
captured in photos as design samples
then recorded in the paradise planning
portfolio
to view the portfolio use this nook
phone app happy home network
from the app you can visit the homes of
previous clients and see how they're
doing
[Music]
by connecting online you'll be able to
share your design with people from all
over the world
follow the designers you like
and view their designs to spark
inspiration for your own
[Music]
use the animal crossing series amiibo
figures and amiibo cards to invite
clients of your choosing and discuss
their ideal vacation homes
with amiibo you can design vacation
homes for these busy individuals
[Music]
the vacation homes you design for them
will hopefully make them very happy
design techniques acquired while working
with a paradise planning team can be
used on your island
experiment with partition walls counters
pillars
[Music]
lighting
soundscapes
you can also polish your own furniture
to spruce up your home
and by gifting your residents a special
souvenir from paradise planning they may
become interested in what the
archipelago has to offer
they may even ask you to design a
vacation home for them
[Music]
who knows someday after you've designed
a certain number of homes you might even
be able to suggest home remodels to your
island residents
[Music]
what do you think
turning every character's dream into a
reality with thorough and creative
design that's the work of paradise
planning
there's a spot open for you to join
their team and start designing
animal crossing new horizons happy home
paradise launches on november 5th as
paid additional content for animal
crossing new horizons
[Music]
pre-orders begin october 29th on
nintendo eshop
you can purchase animal crossing new
horizons happy home paradise on its own
or experience the paid additional
content as part of nintendo switch
online plus expansion pack the new
membership plan for nintendo switch
online
please visit the official website for
more details on nintendo switch online
plus expansion pack
in addition the fifth series of the
animal crossing amiibo cards will be
available
48 cards including characters previously
not on amiibo cards as well as new ones
will be released at the same time as the
update
series 5 of the animal crossing amiibo
cards will be released on november
check your local retailer for details
[Music]
thanks for watching the animal crossing
new horizons direct
we help you'll savor an even sweeter
island life and relish in the new design
experience
see you on november 5th
[Music]
you